أنا فقط لا أصدق أنه
اكتشفت الرجل الذي حاول قتلها في
مقاطعة الحجر الجيري في عام 2015 ، الرجل الذي
ساعدت في إدانته وإرساله إلى السجن لمدة
75 عامًا ذهب إلى المحكمة وشهدت
ضده وحُكم عليه لمعرفة
هرب كيسي وايت  ولا أحد يعرف إلى
أين يتجه ، نعم ، كما اعتقدت ،
لن أضطر أبدًا للقلق بشأنه
مرة أخرى ،
هذا فيديو لتطبيق القانون
لإلقاء القبض على الأبيض في عام 2015. الآن مع
أبيض هارب ، هذه المرأة التي خرجت من
الولاية وبدأت  حياة جديدة
مختبئة مع أطفالها وخطيبها خائفين
حتى من البقاء في منزلهم ،
سيظهر الأبيض الخائف للوفاء
بتهديداته
التي تعرفها ذات مرة قبل المجيء إلى
منزلي وحاول قتلي
في تطور لهذه العلاقة المرعبة
هذه المرأة الآن  يعمل كضابط إصلاحي
متحمس لمساعدة الآخرين بعد
محنتها في ألاباما ، حيث يعتبر الأبيض
خطيرًا جدًا على
كل من
حوله وهو مجرد موقف مخيف
إنه مخيف جدًا لكل شخص يتورط فيه  إد
وأنت تعلم أنني فقط لا أريد أن
يؤذي أي شخص آخر ، ولا يحتاج أحد إلى
المرور بهذا الأمر على
الإطلاق ،
ما هي رسالتك إلى فيكي وايت
إذا كانت لا تزال على قيد الحياة
وهو ما لا أعرفه إذا كانت  هو
لأنني أشعر أنه قد تلاعب بها
وأنه يمكن التخلص منها
أم لا
إذا كانت لا تزال على قيد الحياة ، فركض بعيدًا عن
الجحيم ، وركض قدر المستطاع وسلم
نفسك واتصل بشخص ما
مثل افعل الشيء الصحيح قبل أن تفقد
حياتك
أو  قبل أن يفعلها شخص آخر